so i guess we could just talk a bit more
about what you do yeah yeah yeah yeah i
met you guys at a
faku party yeah yeah yeah at anime expo
right here was that 20 was whenever the
last one was 2019.
why are you on what's your youtube
history why the [ __ ] are you on youtube
what's going on with that huh
oh
why am i on youtube yeah one way before
you on youtube oh yeah so oh yeah okay
okay
i get it here okay
so
so i was like i graduated college and
yeah i didn't want to
be an industry
puppet yet
yeah what did you study in college i
went for 3d animation which i hate okay
i hate 3d animations 3d animation i hate
i hate 3d i want 3d animation because
obviously like career-wise it's like
safest yeah like if you go to art
college you're paying like
like 50 grand whatever every semester in
like you know can
massively and death 50 grand every
semester yeah yeah odd college don't
mess around yeah and they make you pay
for the dorms yeah then they make you
pay
for like everything right and then they
give you this lunch card and they're
like we put like fifteen thousand
dollars in here you have to spend it all
or it goes away so you have to keep
eating at the cafeteria to spend all
that money right right where else the
money is useless yeah it's so stupid
anyways
yeah so
after i graduated i was like jobless for
like
a year and a half two years i don't know
how long it was like probably the most
depressing parts of my life yeah it was
very depressing because
at first because i wanted to try to do
something myself like instead of like
being a paint bucket slave like on my
page yeah yeah yeah yeah bucket paint
bucket i was like let me try to do
something
it was a massive struggle oh
i release a video
and then it would do poorly because
obviously when you're like one
subscriber andy you're like yeah yeah
like i can't do much yeah right so then
it was just that i i just uh kept doing
it because i saw like uh people like
like uh dominick's james jaden and stuff
like they were doing well at the time
uh story time animation was like very
well that was crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
it is dying now like a little bit
obviously you think so
i think so yeah dying it's not dying
dying it's calmed down a lot it's calm
down it's definitely not at the peak
yeah it used to be insane you can make
like any video be like i went to school
and i i sat down and i i saw a pencil
and i sharpened it and then you could
get like a million views on it yeah yeah
i remember like when it was at its peak
it was like every yeah no matter how
many times you refresh your home page
yeah yeah there was there was a
different story time review
it worked i think james's like style was
like so simple
that everyone was like oh i could do
that too right right yeah that's what
happened
yeah because i remember like before like
they're like some of the biggest youtube
videos were like animation and then
youtube changed the algorithm to not
like to to to watch time on animation
yeah but people but people that the need
never went so you know there was you
know there was this huge need on and one
on the youtube audience for animation
but obviously it wasn't feasible to do
like the like the heavy new grounds kind
of short form animation anymore and then
that kind of evolved into story time
animations i think it's funny though
it's because they're supposed to be
simpler now but like now everyone has
like teams yeah yeah yeah i wish i had
to i mean i should try to get one but
like
i have that like mental problem where
i'm i'm like i must do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you'll you won't do it
correctly i gotta do it right and i hate
that i hate that yeah that's definitely
something you need to like let go of as
a youtuber
i'm editing right i'm the same way and i
still like i still am heavily involved
in the editing process yeah because
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause like to me to
me that is like my personality like i
can convey my personality through my
editing so i've had to learn what parts
can i give to someone else and not like
lose
like like lose this to be like a giggup
video you know that's that's that's
that's what i've had to like figure out
and that's the what the challenge is
because you can't continue doing
everything yourself you have to figure
out you know what makes a digest video a
dietis video and what can i outsource to
other people to help me with you know
because i'm sure you could get like you
know helpers to do let's say like
coloring and stuff like that that's the
hard part though is that when it comes
to animation it's expensive because
there's a lot of hours that yeah yeah
yeah
and like in my head i'm like well if i'm
doing the writing the storyboarding the
animation the youtube thumbnail the
whatever like there's so many i'm like
doing everything right yeah and i'm like
if i give this to somebody else all
they're gonna do is just make it
polished and make it look better right
but like let's say but i don't
technically save time that way though
there's there's like some things you can
do like just better let's say you're
writing right you could argue that you
have to write everything but what's
wrong with someone kind of mimicking
your style and then you're going in and
cleaning it up and the more you work
with somebody i would love that i just
need a fine line yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's all about writing that fight
it sucks because you need to find
someone but also and then you have to
pay them good you have to join them so
like you don't see a return you pay them
but it's but in the long run you'll
probably see it's an
like i love doing the videos yeah of
course but it it it is a lot of work and
i don't like to say out loud that it's a
lot of work because yeah it's like
it's because it's always a lot of work
no the problem is that there's artists
who are doing that but better or faster
than you or draw better than you yeah
like you know i'd say i'm pretty good
but then picks up artists are like
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but um
we'll take it like what what is like the
pros like your entire process into
making one of your videos and
start from start from start to like end
ah
okay um well first of all you gotta
think of like okay what's like a
good enough video that won't be boring
yeah i i go for like the adhd kind of
like fast pace
yeah right right right um
but but the problem is like i i learned
that the hard way that like i i've been
doing this so much i run out of jokes
because i'm like well i've done this
i've done this def no i've done that
another death note i've done that
i i put so many death note like
references in there already i'm like oh
well i need to like
change my style or something
i'm running out of jokes man right
but uh yeah so i just start with the
topic and you
you half write it you bullet point yeah
and you storyboard storyboarding is the
longest because right that's basically
the whole video and then you just have
to clean it up right right so storyboard
oh yeah sorry you got to do the audio
because now you got to match the audio
with the storyboard yeah and then and i
hate the audio the most i hate audio the
most
why why'd you hate audio
when it's like a home setup it's like
i don't know i have a
i have a hard time like because with
with animation every
sentence that you make is at least like
five to ten drawings yeah you're like
okay i gotta cut this down so i don't
have to like animate like an extra 30 40
50 60 drawings so you have to like cut
it like perfectly right right right
to save you some drawing time exactly
and um i don't know i just feel like the
expectations are like really high
uh for
any artist on youtube yeah because
there's always gonna be that guy in the
comments that's like well that's it
that was [ __ ] or something like that
yeah yeah
like i don't know there's always that
guy that's that's like what what
happened your quality went down well
well my quality went down because i have
to release the video yeah you want it
faster right yeah yeah you take too long
they go where's the video
and then it kind of like it burns you up
i want to say i'm burnt out i would say
like i would make the video then i get
like burnt out for like a month yeah and
then i come back but at least i like
enjoy it yeah i'll do it again i'll keep
doing it
the pro the problem was like i don't
know this uh animation or story time or
whatever they made this
like this
thing in the air which is like oh you
gotta do it monthly monthly right why i
don't like a standard i think that's
probably like an expectation of like
this seems like a reasonable amount of
time right
and like but also i probably said that's
like youtube's like
a good way to remind youtube that you
still exist and like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah please recommend my video so things
like when when we mean emily do like
stuff with connor on his channel or
whatever yeah it's like hey we're still
live we're just
suffering from animating
i tried not to draw more than like three
frames i'm just like yeah yeah because
the most of it is the jokes and the
audio yeah yeah yeah um and then the
visuals are just like bonus yeah some
animators don't they don't they take
that too lightly and they animate too
much and then they
they're like oh man why'd i do this
right right
how long does it take like to make one
of your videos do you reckon like like
without rushing it yeah without rushing
like hours well the thing is like
in a mental you need to be oh sorry
sorry i want to make sure it's like
pointed towards your mouth
yeah so um
you can move it around if uh how long
does it take to uh make one of your
videos like if you're not rushing all
right okay so like the thing is you need
to be in like the mental state like
because i think like you guys are i call
you guys um live-actioners
i'm not a live-actioner
a flesh flesh humor
whether you like it or not
that sounds like a toy that sydney just
bought you know [ __ ] like that that's
something
[Laughter]
but like for you guys like you you can
like set up everything and then be done
within like an hour two or three yeah
not necessarily all depends yeah well it
depends yeah yeah yeah right i'm not
saying like it it's easy i'm saying it's
like
um it's more
streamlined yeah yeah yeah yeah like if
you're not feeling it for the day of
like uh doing the camera yeah like worst
case scenario you like down by a day
yeah yeah yeah yeah or like you just put
up with it you're just like i'm still
gonna record even though like i feel
like [ __ ] yeah well we do
taste yeah
i mean there's some days obviously where
one of us is really tired or whatever
yeah like you know we're not drinking or
something yeah yeah like oh we gotta do
it yeah exactly yeah yeah i think it's
just like you just gotta turn on your
brain if you if you're working on like a
a film set or something or a tv show
yeah you don't get to be like sorry guys
uh i'm feeling a little tired yeah yeah
yeah it's like you just gotta like
because
now it's not just us right even even
then i would still be like all right
yeah just do it yeah we have like a
bunch of staff coming in so it's like if
one of us just doesn't turn up or take
care of ourselves it's like it affects
everyone yeah you have like a staff too
like you we have like responsibilities
yeah
that's how i feel when like maylene
brought us over to geeks plus i'm like
okay well now i i gotta work yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's it's it's like
it's a good motivator it's good
motivation yeah it's like it's like when
you go to a gym with a bro right and
you're supporting them because you don't
you don't want to let your bro's down
right you know yeah because if you you
know you go gym sometimes you like yeah
yeah i'll skip the last set yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna punish me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what are you doing we got
one more set yeah yeah you're like [ __ ]
okay all right i'll do it all right yeah
i thought that i felt that like when i'm
near you guys or over there or whatever
i i feel that and i appreciate it like i
i'm like oh this is why
there's three reasons why one uh
motivation yeah and then two food
we all eat food yeah yeah
that is true i can love food okay
i
well now there's like different motor
vehicles now i have to pay for rent
i find as a creator when you're around
other people who are very determined you
know making things being very like
proactive and are really like pushing
their
content at the limits it very much
influences me yeah absolutely
yeah i think we all stepped up our game
from from being in trash taste and we
all wanted to push each other yeah stuff
like i've definitely learned so much
just by being on trash taste and just
being with the boys as well like this
year has been like i've been outputting
the most content i've ever outputted in
my entire career i miss when you used to
like not post
[Laughter]
i was like my brother
i remember i remember these two would
post like so fast and i'm like i can't
keep up this is like years and years ago
yeah when he was working at the bbc i
could keep up with going because he
would like release like one video every
like three months and i'm like three
months three months
yeah once a year once every six months
or maybe it was like it was like a bunch
of yeah yeah yeah it was like dangerous
like he's like he's just like me
up this game yeah no i mean i'm glad for
the boy
thank you
down guys no i
but uh yeah i got some new ideas to like
up the uh yeah hey guys i'm still lively
yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah because
with the animations because like i'd say
like
i've learned a lot by being on trash
chase because it was like the process of
this is like so different from being uh
like a non-flesh tuber like what what
did you call that what you i don't know
what to do
[Laughter]
no yeah because i was just i was just
like a disembodied voice you know like i
had never shared my face or anything but
like all of my content like you was like
very scripted you know like highly
edited and stuff like that so i would
have like you know aside from the
drawing i would have like a sem a very
similar process i i i i noticed that
yeah yeah and like the big difference
between working on trash taste and
working with you know live action videos
is that there is like there is like a
clear
separation between okay work starts
camera is on you are working now cameras
stop recording
job's over or like videos stop redo yeah
yeah yeah yeah but like there is a clear
separation be like okay my work here is
done i can just relax whereas with
scripted videos and with like edited
videos you're just like oh i could maybe
do a little bit more just too much
potential yeah yeah yeah yeah like you
got too much you waste too much time
exactly exactly there's no clear
separation about when you should start
and when the project is over yeah
because there's always like a little a
little bit you can do more